I don't think for a second the Kissinger
would support a British exit from the
European Union,
nor would I,
but the reason why he would be skeptical
about it,
it's probably rather different from the
typical reasons that are put forward
these days in the debate because it's
not really about economics,
which is conventionally how we tend to
debate these things are the argument
here is a strategic one.
Britain is still one of the world's
powers,
maybe not a great part,
but still a significant power,
but the European Union allows it to
magnify its power and this is something
that I think is an undeniable fact and
without it,
I think Britain would be much diminished
in the realm of foreign policy.
If you want to understand what it's like
to be a European country outside the EU,
take a trip to Switzerland and ask them
how it's going to be part of Europe,
but have no vote.
Have no say so.
I think you know,
my own sense is,
although I'm not trying to second guess
him,
that world order strongly implies a
British membership of the EU.
Remember,
there's an angler file strand to
Kissinger.
He had from an early age and early
stage,
very good friends in this country
ranging across the political spectrum
from the great historian Michael Howard,
to Dennis Ed.
When he came to Europe.
Kissinger really meant he came to France
to Germany and to Great Britain.
He spent relatively little time in other
countries except occasional trips to
Italy,
but his view of Europe I think was one
that combined and understanding of the
need for Britain to be engaged with
Europe and and understanding that Europe
security was very much a factor for
NATO.
So my sense is that the whole argument
of the most recent book he wrote,
World Order is that Europe is itself a
power,
but it's a power that must reform
itself.
It's a power that risks impotence
through its own internal entanglements,
its own internal internal complexities
and the whole point.
I think if the government strategies is
to argue for reform of Europe rather
than than for exit from it.